And everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Conners, and we're going to go over some information
on stages of an autoimmune disease.
So if we're talking about autoimmune phase of Lyme, then understand that the definition
of that is that you have eotebodies to self-tissue.
Here, autoimmune Hashimoto's, the definition of that is that you have eotebodies to self-tissue
in that case, the thyroid gland.
With Lyme disease, it could be of any organ, any tissue in your body, with M.S.
It's antibodies to the myelin sheath cells, or logodendrocytes, in your brain.
That's destroyed the myelin sheath, with rheumatoid factor, it's antibodies to collagen, or
with lupus antibodies to DNA.
So we're going to get into that and talk about the stages then of an autoimmune disease.
So we talked about in multiple places, if you have self-antibodies through a lab test,
that is by definition an autoimmune disease, and they're named after what tissue is being
destroyed, what tissue you have antibodies against.
But there's another factor that's involved, and that is a stage of an autoimmune disease.
And I'm going to give credit where credit to do, Dr. DeTis Caratzian is my mentor, who I've
learned so much from, if you are a practitioner viewing this video, highly recommend a practitioner
that you go and take Dr. DeTis Caratzian's courses.
He's got multiple courses, he's got one autoimmune disease, but that's where a lot of this information
is taken from.
So giving credit to Dr. DeTis Caratzian, and everything that I've learned from him, I'm
trying to make this simple for patients.
So please forgive me as we go through this, if it seems well too complicated.
So the different stages of an autoimmune disease are labeled stage 1, 2, and 3, stage 1 being
silent autoimmune disease.
That means the person may test in a blood test of having elevated antibodies to self-tissue
of some kind, yet they don't really have any symptoms of the antibodies to that self-tissue.
We'll get into a full description of this, so hold on with me.
Stage 2 is what's called autoimmune reactivity, meaning that you also have elevated antibodies
to a self-tissue, but your symptoms and clinical noticeable loss of tissue just isn't there.
So you may have symptoms like, okay, I'm talking about rheumatoid arthritis.
My joints hurt, but I may not have any visible x-ray signs or I may not have any visible swelling.
So there's not as the clinical assertation isn't there, it's based upon symptoms in the blood
test.
And then stage 3, and there's a lot of fluidity between these as you're going to see.
Stage 3 autoimmune is full autoimmune disease where you have elevated antibodies, you have
symptoms, and you have a very measurable tissue destruction of some kind.
And the different autoimmune diseases, named after different tissues, there's some clinical
argument you could say on whether a person's in stage 2 or stage 3, because based upon different
research, you have to have x amount of percentage of tissue destruction in order to be in stage
3.
From a clinical standpoint, it really doesn't make any difference.
You should be treating stage 2 and stage 3 very similarly.
You certainly should be treating stage 1 as if you could potentially have full-blown stage
3, because a person could move from stage 1 to stage 3 literally overnight.
And a person could stay in stage 1 for decades, a person could stay in stage 2 for decades.
They have some symptoms, they've never really, the symptoms have not gotten worse.
They still have these achy joints at different times, changes maybe with the weather and
such, but they've never gone into full tissue damage where they have deformities in their
fingers and noticeable swelling, and so they've stayed in a stage 2.
But if you don't start looking at the fact that you have symptoms of autoimmune disease,
you could easily flip to stage 3, and that at that time, it makes it much more difficult
to care for.
And once you already have measurable tissue destruction, some of those things are not reversible.
Most of those things are not reversible.
Once you have measurable tissue destruction, when you have gross abnormalities in your joint
capsule formation and the arthritis that's going on with rheumatoid arthritis and deformity
of the joints, those are not reversible things, so it's not a matter of detoxing heavy metals
and you're going to be all better and your symptoms are going to go away.
You move to that stage 3.
So many times it takes years or decades from going to stage 1 to stage 3, sometimes it
can just take days from move to stage 1 to stage 3, depending on the disease itself and
multiple other factors.
There's different types of autoimmune disease.
We covered this in other videos.
They're named after the tissue that's being affected, it's named after the protein in
the tissue that's being that the person has created antibodies against.
So there's multiple different proteins in different tissues that you can create antibodies
against, and that's really the name of the autoimmune disease that you're going to have.
When we look at autoimmune disease, there's so many multiple immune factors of autoimmunity.
This comes from Dr. Karatsian's course.
These are factors that you're having to deal with when you're trying to look at this from
a clinical perspective.
This person may have depressed white blood cell production, leading to immune dysregulation.
So autoimmunity always has to do with something going on that's causing some sort of immune
dysregulation, causing an immune suppression in this case.
They could have an active infection.
You see this with Lyme disease, you can see this with mold, but you can see this with other
vector board illnesses, other viruses, even coxaxi virus, which is common to everybody.
They end up with a pathogen upregulation of the immune system, and that could cause a cascade
of effects that could cause an increased cytokine production and you could develop antibodies
wherever that infection is, just based upon the increased hyperimmune response at that
area.
So that you develop antibodies wherever that hyperimmune response is to tissues so they're
surrounding that area.
It could cause barrier permeability, not just intestinal with leaky gut issues, but certainly blood
brain barrier, which is even more serious damage to the astrocytes, leading to all sorts
of problems in antibody production of antibodies, development to neural tissue, which is a very
scary thing, but it's all too common.
Overactive phagocytes, cell activity means overactivity of your immune cells, your monocytes,
neutrophils, eocinophils, etc.
That could cause an autoimmune cascade and your body making antibodies against tissue based
upon that, complement protein, which are complement proteins we talked about in another video
are like little landmines throughout your body.
And if those aren't being regulated, killing pathogens, then you could have that upregulation
and growth of pathogens, overgrowth, causing an immune reaction, causing antibody production
to self tissue.
Though this goes on, I won't go through all of this.
There's too many things to go through.
We're only going to touch on just the different stages in this video and how this relates to how
you would address it as a clinician and how you would address this as a patient.
I want you to see the seriousness of it, but I want you to see the complexity of this too.
I know that our courses, we never want to give anybody the idea that it's just a simple
fix.
You're just like one supplement away from a magic cure, or there's just one tool away from
causing all your symptoms to go away.
I certainly don't want to be a pie of the sky practitioner that's leading you on to something
that isn't true, because I think at least I've been a practitioner for a lot of years
and the number one thing I hear from people, let's say, with chronic Lyme, or chronic autoimmune
disease, is that they don't want to feel misled because they've been misled by different
practitioners, which I think is very sad.
Practitioners that say, well, oh yeah, we can cure you of this disease.
I'll, when you just follow our protocol, and this is the cure for Hashimoto's or this
is the cure for chronic Lyme, it's never that simple.
When you have self antibodies, it's not about curing, it's about managing, it's about you
learning the complexity of it so that it calms your mind and gives you the sense of control
back that, hey, okay, maybe I'm never going to be cured of this chronic Lyme or the symptoms
that I'm having from it, but I'm going to be able to better self-manage it and keep
myself from flares, and what I do get this horrible flair, I know what to do to help calm it
down.
It's not going to be magic, it's not going to be an easy solution, but it's better to understand
what's going on so that you could better self-manage it, not just from a physiological standpoint
but from a mental standpoint, but you don't think that you're going crazy because this
is what I hear all the time, and that nobody, you've been to a million doctors and nobody
understands you, nobody can diagnose you, nobody can figure this out, and the reason is
it's because it's very complex, and that's what I want these videos to get to.
It is a very complex situation, but there are some manageable tools, so if you could wrap
your head around the complexity of it and then understand that, okay, now, what do I have
to do now?
I understand that this is complex, I'm not looking for a solution that's going to magically
erase this, but I'm looking for a solution of how I could calm this down.
Getting back to our talk here, there's organ-specific autoimmune diseases, many of you have been diagnosed
with that, multiple sclerosis as an organ-specific autoimmune disease, antibodies to myelin sheath
cells, and now you got a immune destruction of myelin sheath cells, thyroiditis, Hashimoto's,
you have antibodies, TPO antibodies to the thyroid gland, and now you can have a immune destruction
of the thyroid gland.
An organ-specific autoimmune disease is destructive enough, and looking at the triggers that fire
that look at the cross-reactive things that fire this autoimmune disease, that rampant
up and make it worse is complex enough.
It gets more complicated when we deal with systemic autoimmune diseases.
So systemic autoimmune disease like systemic lupus or rheumatoid arthritis is even more complex
because not only do you have antibodies to a particular tissue, but with systemic autoimmune
disease, you have antibodies to DNA and or collagen, and the problem is how many organs
have collagen, how many organs have DNA, all of them.
So all of your tissue has DNA because every cell has DNA, so that you can get multiple autoimmune
diseases, multiple diagnoses because you're developing antibodies to DNA or collagen, it becomes
a much more serious disease.
So systemic autoimmune diseases, it's really finding those triggers, we're going to go over
treatment in such in another video, but you're looking for triggers, looking to calm down
this immune response, looking to up-regulate T-regs as cells, depending on whether it's
TH-1 or TH-2 dominant, you're looking at balancing that back out.
There are some treatment parameters that you have to go through.
However, it's all about managing and trying to calm down and trying to get into a state
where things have settled down, and the disease is much more manageable, and you are self-regulating
yourself.
That's the idea in all of these disorders, where we're talking about autoimmune disease.
Here's a good test that you can have a practitioner run.
This is called an ANA comprehensive panel, my lab core, but a lot of other quest labs and
other labs may run these panels, but this, you'll notice in this panel, it's looking at
anti-DNA antibodies to DNA.
It's looking at different, this is show-grins, anti-body test here, anti-cromatine antibodies.
This is giving you a nice picture of DNA antibodies.
This particular example is the sample report.
None of them are flagged.
This person is negative for these, but if a person has positive DNA antibodies, the case
just got much more complex because any cell can be affected and we're really working on
just call me that down.
Another lab test that you can look to rule out some systemic DNA antibodies, which makes
a case even more serious.
So again, back to our stages, silent autoimmunity, I have elevated antibodies, but I really don't
have any symptoms or loss of tissue.
Most of these people are going to do a blood test to find this out, unless you have maybe
other symptoms going on and you go to a functional medicine doctor that's going to run a antibody
profile.
It's very beneficial to do if you were exposed to Lyme or you were exposed to Mold, but running
that Ray-5 antibody profile from Cyrex will look at some examples of that could be very
beneficial to that person, even if they don't have any symptoms, and they will find that
sometimes that they have symptoms and they'll have antibodies that relate to those symptoms,
but then they have antibodies to other tissue that they have yet to have symptoms, and so
they might actually be in stage one autoimmune disease with antibodies present in one organ,
but maybe a stage two or stage three with symptoms, and maybe stage three with even symptoms
and tissue destruction in another organ, and I'll show you in some examples here.
So when you're looking at evaluating a person for autoimmune disease, they may have elevated
increased levels of self-tissue antibodies, antibodies to self-tissue of some organ, and then
you evaluate, do they have clinical signs and symptoms, usually if they're at a practitioner's
office, they came in because they had clinical signs and symptoms, and then you did the
test for elevated antibodies, so usually it's reversed in a clinical setting here, they
have the signs and symptoms present, and then you're deciding whether in stage two autoimmune
reactivity or stage three, and you have to do further testing and examination to determine
that, and that will guide the treatment phase.
Here's a perfect example of somebody that might be in phase two, or somebody that might
be in phase three, stage two or stage three of autoimmune disease, the younger hand there,
this has to do with rheumatoid arthritis, the younger hand here is starting to develop
clinical findings, they have joint swelling, obviously prior to this, they probably had
pain for maybe some time, remember you can move from stage one to stage three relatively
quick, then the older looking hands here, obviously in stage three rheumatoid arthritis, severe
physical deformity of the joints, that's something that is not going to be correctable, it's
something that you're going to want to manage, and hopefully decrease the inflammation, and
there might decrease the person's pain, remember what's the pain is, cause for inflammation,
if you could do things to will decrease the inflammation and manage this patient, you're
not going to change the clinical findings of the deformity, but you can change the symptom
pattern to improve the quality of this person's life.
If you could catch this person in, let's say the younger person's hand, they already are
getting swelling, maybe in stage two or stage three already, cause you can see the clinical
findings, if you could catch them at an earlier stage, meaning you did a profile, this is an
array five from CyRex Labs, the labs that we recommend for autoimmune testing, and you can see
this array five runs through 27 different multiple autoimmune reactivities, so anything in the yellow
or red is positive, and the yellow does not mean that it's in a different stage than a red,
so here in this case, look at this example, this is showing positive equivocal in the yellow
for intrinsic factor, well intrinsic factor is the process and how you absorb vitamin B12,
it's in your stomach and intrinsic factor, you can develop antibodies to that protein in
a trinsic factor, and then you can end up with B12 deficiency, because you have an autoimmune
reaction to intrinsic factor, in this case, this person does, let's say they have no symptoms
of B12 deficiency, we do a B12 test, that's within normal levels, they have no fatigue, they have
no homocysteine issues, which would be common with if they had, if they were in stage two or stage three,
intrinsic factor autoimmunity, so they're in stage, they could very well be in stage one
intrinsic factor, maybe you did this test because in this case the patient had chronic inflammatory
joint pain, but then you found that they also have antibodies to intrinsic factor, well I don't have
any symptoms of fatigue, I don't have any symptoms of homocysteine issues, I don't have any other
blood tests that show any relativity to having antibodies to a intrinsic factor, but remember a
person could move from stage one to stage three overnight, they should start doing things as if
they have full blown autoimmune disease to intrinsic factor because that could cause
major other symptoms like chronic fatigue and all sorts of issues that could cause other health
issues too, if they stop absorbing B12, they it's a whole cascade of things that could happen
through the methyonine pathway, that you want to address now, now that you have this test,
even if the patient came to you with chronic inflammatory joint pain, it had no symptoms
signs or anything that led you to think that they had any intrinsic factor issues, so does it
hopefully that explains that, so but in this case this person has antibodies to collagen complex,
so but remember let's say this patient came to me, they have chronic inflammatory joint pain,
that was their main symptom, and let's say I have this horrible joint pain, I think they have
Lyme disease, we run array five, and sure enough we have antibodies to collagen complex,
so what tissues have collagen complex, well certainly your joints have collagen complex,
this could be the cause of all their joint pain, they have an autoimmune reaction to collagen,
and it's affecting their joints, so every time this immune system is sparked and it attacks
collagen, this person's symptoms get worse, now we have to dig in to the rest of the story and see
this is the treatment phase that we'll talk about in another video, what is sparking this immune
reaction, is it food, is it this person's diet, is it an environmental thing, is it heavy metals,
is it exposure to other tick bites, is it exposure to other viruses or bacteria, or is it mold,
is it EMFs, is it this is where it gets really complex, we already know they have antibodies to
collagen complex, we know that they're in stage two or stage three because they have symptoms,
so remember again, stage one is they have antibodies, but no symptoms, no clinical findings,
stage two is they have antibodies, and they have symptoms, but not a lot of clinical findings,
stage three is they have antibodies, they have symptoms, and they have a lot of clinical findings,
so based upon this person's history, based upon the examination, based upon other knowledge,
we know that this person with chronic inflammatory joint pain has collagen complex antibodies,
they're making antibodies to collagen, every time it's definitely affecting their joint,
because they have joint symptoms, let's say they have other objective findings on examination,
they could be in stage two or stage three autoimmunity, so we need to now dig into the rest of the
story, what's firing this up, we can't erase the fact that they have antibodies to collagen complex,
that if any functional practitioners say that they can cure your autoimmune disease,
they're saying that they can cure the fact that you have antibodies to collagen complex,
and I'm sorry, but they're lying to you, that just doesn't exist, we need to calm that down,
and antibodies to self-tissue can dissipate and can decrease, and that's the whole idea,
we need to calm the reason why that's flaring up, down as much as possible, and that's going to be
some trial and error effort in that. Notice also in this example, that this person, in this example,
also has antibodies to synapses, well synapses is an upper motor neuron component of your joint,
of the neuron joints, or the neuron complexes, called synapses, so if you're making antibody to your
neural synapses in your brain, holy cow, you're damaging your neural tissue, so let's pretend this
person goes, I don't have any brain issues, I'm not having any memory issues, I'm not having any
anger issues, I'm not having any emotional issues, I'm not having any other symptoms that they're
dealing with, well actually if they have inflammatory chronic inflammatory joint pain, not to get too
complicated, they could have inflammation and destruction of the synapses if the
parietal over the brain causing the pain of their joints, so it gets a little complicated, doesn't it?
We need to figure this out, regardless, you could still, this person might only be in, let's say,
pretend it's possible that they're only on stage one as far as the synapses, and if it flips to
stage three, you're talking about major brain issues and we certainly don't want to do that, we
certainly don't want to see that, just like with the intrinsic factor antibodies, maybe they're only in
stage one, they can flip to stage three, when you're talking about brain, when you're talking about
antibodies to brain neural tissue, you do not want to be in stage three, okay? So we know this person
is at least in stage one, this is an example patient, we know they're at least in stage one,
based upon their symptoms of chronic inflammatory joint pain, that could actually be coming from
the synapses and antibodies, even more so than the collagen complex antibodies, because if the synapses
and antibodies are inflamed and being destroyed in the parietal over the brain has to do a sensory
function of the brain, and that's where you actually actually feel joint pain is in the parietal
over the brain, that could be actually the cause of the person's symptomatic picture. So you can see
how it gets complex, we need to calm this down, you can't erase the antibodies, the practitioner's job
is not to erase the antibodies, your auto mood is going to go away, it just does not, that's why I say
auto mood disease is something that you work towards, managing, it's not something that you work
towards, cured, so we need to work on how we're going to manage this and calm this down, hopefully
that can help explain it, so this person, if this was the blood test, array five, from the person with
the younger hands there, that could be the reason exactly the collagen complex definitely,
so if they have changes in their joint capsule, then we know that that is coming from the collagen
complex, if they don't have changes in their joint capsule, but they have severe pain in their
hands, it could actually be coming from the synapses, you could actually have the symptoms coming from
both, either one of the younger person's hands or the older person's hands, hopefully that's
not too complicated, I know it's hard to digest all this information, sometimes you can listen to this
a couple times, here's an example of a patient with Hashimoto's, so Hashimoto's is a Hashimoto's,
it has to with your thyroid, you have antibodies to your thyroid, super, super common condition,
EDUC books out there that say we're going to cure your Hashimoto's, it's nonsense, here's an example
of a person, if you do this array five on the person, thinking that you're just going to find
what you see the first positive here, the red out of range, which is the thyroid,
peroxidase, the TPO antibodies, they have antibodies to their thyroid gland,
well that makes sense because they are already diagnosed with Hashimoto's, they might have already
done a TPO antibody test with the thyroid profile and it was positive, but then oh my goodness,
we have some other things, positive here, we have antibodies to the over your testes,
depending on whether this person is a male or female, we have antibodies to osteocytes, we have
antibodies to gangliocytes and alpha tubulins and beta tubulins, those two things are antibodies
to the brain, very serious, the osteocyte antibodies, this is what can cause osteoporosis,
chronic inflammatory response, the periosteum of the bone and the endosteum of the bone,
causing just erosion, decay of the bone causing osteoarthritis,
what if this person is 25 years old and they're hoping female, hoping to have children and they
have antibodies to the ovaries, so antibodies in autoimmune disease to your ovaries can be the
cause of infertility, so there's multiple things going on here, and this person only thought they
had Hashimoto's, very valuable test to know, even if the person is only in stage one on all these
other antibodies, but they're obviously doing this test, let's pretend because they know they have
Hashimoto's and they're, they're, they're already unsyntheroid, they already know that they're in stage
autoimmune response for Hashimoto's, we do this test at UC antibodies to other self tissue,
you need to start taking action to, to help calm that response to those other antibodies or
this person's gonna have a lot worse problems than having to be unsyntheroid to the rest of their
lives, very valuable test, you can see understand again, make sure you understand that just because
you're in yellow, does not mean you're in stage two, or red, you're in stage three, that has,
that has the, the, the level of antibody has really nothing to do with stage urine, people get
that confused, some people go into, they do a thyroid test and they're measuring TPO antibodies,
so they're all excited cause their antibodies went down, or they're really bummed because their
antibodies, their TPO antibodies go up, really the level of antibodies in a test is somewhat insignificant,
it has nothing to do with telling us what stage you're in, so your stage that your in has to do with
tissue destruction, or noticeable symptoms, it does not have to do with a level of antibodies,
I have to clarify that quite often when people talk to me about their TPO antibodies, the most
common thing that they measure because they measure TPO antibodies with a, with a complete
thyroid panel panel, and they go, my symptoms have gotten so much better after doing XYZ,
but my TPO antibodies went up and they think, oh my gosh, I need to take more
Syntheroid, and my doctors telling me to take more Syntheroid cause my TPO antibodies went up,
that is totally wrong information, they're not understanding autoimmune function, so make sure
you're clarified in your mind regarding that, so the yellow or red or the level of antibody that
you have does not equate to what stage you're in, the stage has to do with whether there's tissue
destruction and or symptoms, so, but when you have antibodies, you have antibodies, and they're not
going to go away, with, you know, I just take a magic pill, or you're just one supplement away,
or one drug away from making these go away, you have to manage these, know what flares them up,
know how to deal with them, and that's going to take some, some work on your part.
Here's another example of patient with clinical symptoms, a clinical patterns of demyelination,
so they might have already have a knowledge that they have MS, but then we do a workup on them like
this, they have thyroid, TPO antibodies, they have antibodies to a trinsic factor, they have antibodies
to myelin protein, which we already thought that because they already were diagnosed with MS,
but they have other brain antibodies as well, phospholipid antibodies, what cells have phospholipid,
all your cell membranes, every single cell membrane has phospholipids in it, what is else is
important with fossil phospholipids, it's what how you make bile, that's has to do with phase two
and three of your liver detox pathways, it becomes much more complicated case when you start looking at
this and say, well, maybe this is why you've got some of these other symptoms, you want to evaluate
all these things, whether they're in stage one, two, or three, regardless of what stage they're in,
you need to see what triggers these things, see what are the cross reactants to these things,
it gets very complicated for the patient and it can get very depressing, but I don't want you
to be depressed by this, I want you to have this knowledge, give you, oh, well, this, a reason why,
okay now I'm starting to understand why I have these symptoms, why nobody's been able to figure
this out, why I've been kind of misled by false promises, I'm not going to have that happen again,
I want to take control of my body, I want to dig into how I'm going to calm this down and I'm not
going to give that control to anybody, another practitioner, anybody, I'm going to do this and learn
how to, to calm down the fire that's going on inside my body because that's really what's going on,
so learning the stages of auto-immunity is important, learning where you have, you know,
what tissues you have antibodies to if you do is important and then we're going to get into some
videos on how to then calm that down and use some different tools to help calm it down, doing other
tests, I like Syrex test and you'll find out why as I go through Syrex 10 and why it's really important
to measure food antibodies because we have to eat constantly and we are eating things that are,
that are firing an immune reaction, it's going to affect everything else that I have antibodies against,
I made that very clear in a lot of my videos in all my courses, anything that you, anything,
once you have self antibodies and you're firing an immune reaction, it can cause problems,
especially if you have an auto-immune disease that your TH1 dominant, so we'll go through those
in detail, so I know there's a lot of information stick with me and we're going to keep uncovering this,
to give you power and to give you the ability to see a little bit more clearly that this isn't simple
but that's okay that it's not simple because I'm going to be able to take care of this and learn
how to manage it, all right, I love you guys, I'll be praying for you, again, I want to give credit
to Dr. DeTis Cratsian, if you're a practitioner, make sure you look up his courses, it'll be very valuable for you, thanks.